now they're heading like I said is
revision of graphing in calculus we're
going to cover a bunch of things that
you already know of and have encountered
but perhaps we're not seeing them all
together one of the things we do in math
often is we say here's a particular
skill it's a particular skill we're just
going to make you really really good at
that one skill so when I learned to play
the acoustic guitar
um I first picked it up when I was your
age what I would do was I just make the
same chord like just a single chord over
and over again with my hand I'd like put
the court my fingers on the strings and
I'd relax and then I go straight back
because I was trying to develop muscle
memory now of course it's not a single
song in the world it's just one chord
right like four chord songs okay not one
chord songs but in order to develop that
strength I had to focus on that over and
over again but music happens when you
take a variety of skills a variety of
course and then you combine them okay
so these are things that you've seen
over a space of time are we going to put
them into one pace together
let's get started you got the function
right up the top this one you should
write down because we're gonna be using
it working with it all the way through
we've got f of X with an x squared
outside the front of X minus one so what
family of functions does this f of X
what family functions does it belong to
what would you call it it's a very good
it's a cubic you don't see X cubes
written anywhere yes but we can on the
next line if you like show by expanding
this that it's a cubic what's the
expansion it's a really easy one that's
why I started you off with it X to the
power of three Oh cute take away just X
very good so when you expand it out it
makes it a little more obvious that it's
a cubic but I handed it to you in this
factorized form to sort of nudge you
along and help you with some of these
other pieces let's begin right at this
halt we're gonna graph this guy
okay so Part A we're going to graph now
we'll need a set of axes here please get
out a ruler if you don't have one number
one fix that because we're not going to
be here to lend you a rule out when
you're in your AP is number two if you
don't have one right now shoot your hand
up because you'll need it okay let's get
a set of axes on here
okay now as will often happen in an
assessment task I've tried to note you
in the right direction by a giving in
the question itself a bit of guidance
for what we want to see on this graph so
you can see it says graph y equals a
function of X and slightly wampie I'm
going to fix that axis graph that but
don't just graph it they just draw me a
line I want to show what I want to show
so I said again yes after I show y
equals that right what am i searching
for what features have been named in the
question I'll find my Y and my X
intercepts so once I look back and draw
a much straighter line it's somewhat bit
up okay how do I find for example an
x-intercept there's gonna be more than
one how do I find an x intercept that's
go ahead make y equals zero so I've got
here f of x and y they're the same thing
right there in Part A right so to make y
equals zero to find those X intercepts
I'm gonna say X cubed minus x equals
zero or it could have gone back to the
original form of the line which I
actually think is easier there's going
to be two values of x sorry it's a
really messy x2 values of x that we can
put in that will satisfy this equation
and make the left hand side collapse to
zero anywhere suggest those two values
to me what you can put in here to make
it zero put in X equal zero right if you
put in x equals zero it doesn't matter
that this won't be zero zero times the
thing well is it equal zero so that's
good I'm just gonna jot that down for
myself x equals zero but that's not the
only value that works have a look at
this guy what you want to put in x
equals one this will not be zero but it
doesn't matter because this will be
something times zero also equals zero so
x equals y or x equals one these will be
my x-intercepts you've got yourself a
Cartesian plane there so let's check
these IDs on there's x equals zero
there's x equals 1 let's label them okay
now it just so happens in this case
because I've given you a very simple
function that you found the x-intercepts
but you also found the y-intercept
where is it yeah it's on the origin yeah
so I've done my XM test on my
y-intercept so you're welcome we gave
you a nice easy one is that enough
information to draw the graph it feels
like I could draw a lot of graphs
through that so what else could I do
yeah okay I want to look for a vertex
but it's a bit trickier with a graph
like this because parabolas which you
get from a quadratic they've got one
vertex but cubics don't just have one
vertex they actually have often they'll
have multiple vertices or none so what
can I do to help me with this graph
let's think for a second first about
what's happening to the left and then
what's happening to the right actually
the right easier right if you put in
very large values of X like x equals ten
a hundred a thousand then what's
happening to this thing it's getting
huge right like if I put a hundred in
here
it'll be a 100 squared ten thousand
times 99 big numbers right it's going
it's like skyrocketing up here so
eventually I'm gonna have an arrow going
up this way okay what about over here if
I put it in a large negative value like
negative 100 what's gonna happen well in
the first is this this guy is still
10,000 because you square it right the
negatives gone okay but then what about
this if I put in negative a hundred in
here this becomes negative 101 so
negative 101 7000 whatever it's in other
words it's a big negative number are you
with me so I'm gonna have a line going
down this way arrow line going up this
way arrow and then I just kind of need
to work out what's happening in the
middle so I know it's going to cross the
origin it's going to go through here now
at this point I would suggest for the
tools that we've got access to I want to
think about putting in some values and
being able to work out what's going on
say it again
good question is it going to go straight
through here or is it gonna kind of like
curve away and then come back what do
you reckon well what are you thinking
we could take a number between zero one
because I don't know what's happening in
there and I can substitute in to see
what should be happening and 1/2 looks
like the most obvious one okay
maybe for this case grab your calculator
there so you can do this really easily
right you don't need to sweat your brain
too much on all of this I have been
doing X equal 100 x equals nine hundred
when you put x equals 1/2 in here what's
happening next equals 1/2 someone got a
value for me
negative negative 1/8 so in other words
it's just beneath just down here okay so
it's not above it's down here okay so
what that means is if I'm coming from
down here and I've got to land so I'm
just going to put an arrow down here
just so we know and you've got an arrow
up here that's what we worked out with
our big values and then we'll you've
just told me I'm gonna have to go down
there is this more helpful this is way
more information than I had before right
I just had two spots now I've got like 1
2 3 4 5 spots that I know I'm going to
go through can I give you a second put
this information if you haven't already
on your Cartesian plane and then I want
you to try and trace out we use a pencil
because we may get it slightly wrong
it's fine
trace out where you feel like this graph
is going to go if you get it wrong the
first time that's okay
you've got a pencil use rubber and see
if you can put a shape through that have
a go
so we tested out those large values
remember I asked about X equals 100 and
x equals negative 100
I could have tried a thousand or
negative a thousand all I get is it's
big and it's positive or it's big and
it's negative okay so that's how I just
tried to note let's try it sometimes
okay if you've joined something you
should hold off for me I just want to
say and I'm lazy so don't walk around
all the way okay yep
fantastic thank you okay now some of
these are better than others I'm going
to draw you the graph that I've got okay
now something very very close but here's
what I'm looking for okay now I want you
to look real closely at what's happening
around here in the axis right you can
see these Wiggles are very important
right how do I know that this is exactly
the way it sort of undulated around some
of you have something exactly like this
some of you have something close but
where the wiggle happens is slightly
different okay I'm gonna come to that
we're going to go further into the
question and see if we can do with this
okay